speaking of football he's the head coach
at arizona state good to welcome back
herm edwards how are you doing coach
i'm doing fine my friend and i'm looking
at your uh
your studio there and i'm realizing that
you have a lot of memorabilia there
right
i'm watching it all and i'm looking at
all the little things you have but i i
can tell you this now
you're a pretty good collector of that
stuff i understand you don't have
one of these a herm edwards bobble doll
bobblehead and and now you this is going
to date us
you don't have this oh where you
pick up the fumble the pisarchic
fumble i never saw that one herm
the on yeah look at that somebody
somebody gave this to me it's
unbelievable
i said really is it okay i'll take it
one of the great moments well it was a
great moment for you in nfl history but
that gave you
immortality right that kept
that that kept me occurred right
uh by the way and that's when we
taking a knee was invented because of
that play the missed handoff by joe
pisarcic to
that was larry zonka yes it was correct
oh my god 1978.
we're injuring ourselves partnering with
ourselves do you have that football
i do i have that one and i give you the
next one i have
i've got obviously a few but that was
important but i gave you one that was
most important
my first nfl interception was against
the los angeles rams
in the coliseum and the quarterback was
joe namath
there you go
you know joe is such a great guy he'd
probably sign that if you asked him to
yeah here's a great story so i get it
it's my rookie year
we play the rams and i intercept the
ball and i take it to the sideline
and they put the tape on it right so the
game ends we're walking out of the
coliseum i have the ball i'm a rookie
now
first nfl in reception and i'm walking
and i see joe he's in front of us
and i said i asked a couple of bits you
think he'd automatically
yeah probably not right after the game
but if you saw joe right now
yeah joe would probably do it
did you uh so every interception you had
you kept
no i mean no because i've had what a
33 in a regular and and another five in
playoffs i had about 38 of them yeah
no but there's special ones you know
situations whatever it may be but yeah
i've got a few
uh we talked to chip kelly yesterday and
and he was
you know it wasn't chip kelly the coach
it was chip kelly the person where
he was just saying look you know i
understand it
and you know we're in a hot spot here
and it's tough to be able to tell these
kids that we're not going to be playing
football but there's bigger issues here
and you know you're a deep thinker
you're uh obviously
uh emotional um you know when you first
got the word
that you're not going to play football
how long did it take before then you get
together with your team
it wasn't very long uh they knew you
know they knew a decision was going to
be made
because we were actually we've actually
had walk throughs uh we've been meeting
all those things and i told them when we
get off the field
and we went to the field to have a walk
through i said we're going to know
something and sure enough
by you know one o'clock um i had to
address them
and tell them the news and um it was
very difficult
there's no doubt i think it's different
for everyone when you think about it
but you know this i said this to coach
kelly
and maybe you could help me with this
why aren't we getting the medical
community in the acc sec and you know
the big 12
together with the big 10 and the pac-12
so your doctors their doctors can
exchange
information here herm well you know
that's a good question and i don't know
if they've done that i don't know i
don't want to try to play armchair
quarterback obviously but we knew
going into this that it was going to be
led by our
professionals our healthcare
professionals we knew that when this
thing started like five months ago right
and they were going to give us a game
plan and i think as it got closer than
to
having to really go out and try to
participate in practice
we've had walk-throughs uh they've been
players been working out for two months
but the but the the practice deal
and then obviously with this new thing
about the heart and all that
that all these things became a factor
when they said no and i said this dan
i think every school has done a nice job
of really
creating this bubble that's the big term
now bubble right well
next thursday we start school
a whole different element comes in now
right because
because of socialness of young people
and how do you prevent that how do you
it's hard it's hard but do you even know
what you're allowed to do
as you move forward in the fall as a
head coach well
right now we're under the same uh
requirements we were
uh before we postponed in the fact that
you had 20 hours
now they'll give us a schedule speaking
of schedules
i've got a schedule i've already mapped
out until thanksgiving
what we are going to try to do right and
you got to keep it interesting you got
to keep players engaged which is very
tough
along with coaches uh but that's that's
what we got to try to do right now
but why can you practice and not play
well we
we never practiced it was walk through
okay
not practice okay we were gonna actually
start practicing on the 17th
that never occurred do you think there's
going to be spring football
oh i know you're hoping but i i mean i
you know
there's a lot of balls to juggle uh here
and i think a lot of people
you know are asking the question how can
they play like
a full season i would give them this
if i was in sitting in that seat trying
to orchestrate this and if it came to
fruition where we could play
i would do this in our conference i
would let the south play against the
south and north against the north
that would give you five games uh and
then the winners of both those
conferences played that would give you
six
and you could crown a champion then if
you
came back in the fall you'd actually
play 18 games lsu played 17 games last
year
yeah right so that way
seniors that played six games
it doesn't count they could come back
they could also leave to go to the draft
so you would kind of help both parties
there
and i heard you earlier when you were
talking about
you know people playing like in the
winter
and you're right i mean all of a sudden
the washington schools
you look on your schedule you know our
schedule would be we play utah and
colorado depending when we played them
we'd be okay right if we colorado was
here
we're good we got to go to utah that
you'd only probably get one cold game on
our side of it on the other side at the
washington schools
the oregon schools that gives you a
little bit of a problem with your
stanford maybe
because you'd have to go on those
elements if i
i don't know if your kids your athletes
said hey why is the sec acc
in big 12 playing and we're not playing
coach right i mean that's going to be
the question and
and i told him is this look we're going
to go by the game plan of our physicians
that's what we got to do and i said
we're not going to play armchair
quarterback i'm not going to try to do
it that's not my
i just got to keep you guys whole i got
to keep my coaching staff whole so
i'm wishing them a lot of luck i really
am i'm hoping they can get through it
that would be fantastic um but we'll
just as well the nfl
yeah i mean we're gonna see this thing
unfold
what are you gonna do on saturdays oh
boy
that's a good question yeah well i i
even got the saturday yet
i don't know i mean you know
i know this i dealt with uh the 911 deal
i was the head coach of the jets uh my
first season of rookie head coach and i
dealt with that and i know how that was
like
whoa right it was one of those deals
like are you kidding me
right the unexpected yeah i mean that
was truly the
unexpected and dealing with that for two
weeks
but then the emotion of when we actually
got to play again
we played new england in new england dan
i tell you what
it was unbelievable i mean the national
anthem the flag the just
the whole deal man there was not a dry
eye in the stadium
you know i'm looking forward to that
again
that's what i'm trying to remember when
we actually get back to playing again
that's my hope that's what it's going to
look like when you coached against
belichick
i always wondered do you almost out
coach yourself
in preparing to coach against belichick
well i think the thing that that bill
has done you know and he's a fantastic
hall of fame coach obviously
you always have to understand that you
have to
have the ability to adjust on both sides
of the ball
in other words you could come in with
this plan of well they ran this front
defensively right and you're going to
play against this front and all of a
sudden you think it's a four three and a
half
we got a plan but but the planet can't
be changed is a bad plan you gotta be
able to change your plan
you gotta know that figuring out so it's
always a chess game
but if you understand that going in
you're going to be okay but when you go
against brady
like there's nothing about brady that
like you go oh my god
from the standpoint of the physical
aspect of it you know like there's other
people with better arms
obviously more mobility like all of
these things so now it's the thinking
process of
it it feels like it's harder to
out-think somebody
who's maybe smarter than you than it is
to
take on somebody who has athleticism no
and
and and tom's look i've always said
we're the starter of all this of the of
the tom brady career because
i was sitting here when we knocked out
bledsoe mo lewis hit blesso
and then comes top and it comes this guy
tom brady and he comes in the game and
we're in new england
and we're playing and you know we ended
up winning that game was this low
scoring game
and then he comes back like three or
four weeks later and he and they play us
you know and then you kind of watch him
go
for the rest of my career with captain
america
did you even have a scouting report on
tom brady
we did when he came out you know and uh
it was funny because you know it's like
it's funny because you look at scholarly
personal light and you go hey i get all
that but can the guy play quarterback
and boy can he play quarterback and um
i always tease you when i see him i say
you know i said remember
we get i gave you this opportunity
lewis should go into the hall of fame
yeah and and
and you know what and and i was a little
bit i was
i don't know if i was surprised but
i didn't know i i thought he might not
leave
you know oh i he was so unhappy
he just he wanted to have fun but i
thought
he might be a guy that just ends his
career there you know which is
but and i started laughing i said look
if he wanted to go on the boat
in the end zone i said you know i work
for tampons
i think brady just wanted to have fun
and it's as strange as that may sound to
people
he was in a business i mean that
i i don't know i just think he wanted to
well
like give me some weapons here he goes
down there all of a sudden i got weapons
here
well yeah all of a sudden guys start
coming out of retirement
you know with bruce being down there
bruce aryan's and good friend and we
coach together can't say i've known
bruce forever
it's funny bruce he was the head coach
he was on the temple staff when i was in
philly playing
how about that oh wow and then we worked
together in kansas city when marty was a
coach he was a running back coach right
so
you know bruce will he'll he you know he
he will
relate he'll do things that tom probably
likes you know and like
he said tom was there forever i mean
he's a legend in new england and all
that stuff and
rightly so he deserves yeah i just think
he wanted to
just exhale and you know because it's
always you know who's more important
belichick
or brady and you know they're both
together
hard to be well i want to see what are
you
interested to see what he does with cam
newton
yeah and uh you know i i covered cam in
college
when i was doing sec games and uh i
think this is one of those moments
that cam kind of likes
because people are probably saying well
you know
it'll be interesting chip on his
shoulder yeah kind of that deal right
and um they'll they'll they'll use this
talent now
they will have some design plays in
there where all of a sudden he's running
the ball
right he's coming at you with the ball
in his hand tell you what he's talking
about
oh it's great to catch up with you and
uh
you know if you get lonely and you just
you know you want to talk then you know
you can always you can call me we can
zoom yeah i'm
i'm available over the weekend too
herman we have the same era we can go
back to those
you mentioned outside when the i i i
call them the vikings but they're not
the real vikings
you mentioned how cola was going to be i
can remember going to play those guys
but fran tarkin was a quarterback
and a modern shot it was a receiver and
it was it was
it was so cold right and nate wright had
played db for him
he was he was a friend of mine he comes
by the hotel says hey man you know what
is so cold frank got small hands he
can't he can't throw the ball in these
kind of conditions i said really
so i tell the defensive line
he goes back 52 times
with his small hands in the cold weather
we're outside man
they don't try to remind the shot i said
this ain't a fair fight
oh good oh well
it's great to talk to you i appreciate
your time and uh love your enthusiasm
man ben good luck i know you got a lot
on your plate here coming up but uh
good to check in with you man god bless
you thank you man that's herm edwards
arizona state head football coach